unaccustomed to these moments of calm
Svetlana and her six-year-old daughter
Milana are getting used to life away
from their home city of mariopol they
reached the safety of Kiev just weeks
ago having endured 14 months of fighting
and occupation
everyone thought we were living in a
dream and that one day we would wake up
and all would be good
among those still living there she says
there are high levels of mental stress
and Trauma
people are bitter angry everyone is in
it for themselves now like on a
battlefield it is like another
battlefield for survival
spitlana receives psychological support
at a Reception Center for displaced
people for her it is the start of a
journey for the psychologists a
well-worn path
of course we see ptsdm people who have
experienced extreme stress shock and who
struggle to express it but the
consequence that I worry most about is
that people are becoming used to all
treating violence killings and explosion
as normal this is really scary
that idea of War becoming normalized in
people's lives poses a real risk
psychologists say to the entire fabric
of society add to that the soldiers in
their many thousands scarred and
traumatized who will one day reintegrate
into homes and families and it's a risk
that could well outlive the war itself
already understands what happened after
February 24th so it will be Generations
one person may need 10 years to recover
another will need a lifetime and another
will only write their story at the end
of their life
Tatiana specializes in dealing with
domestic violence often aggravated by
trauma and says that shelters have seen
a marked increase in calls to hotline
numbers since the Russian invasion last
year
this woman was displaced from occupied
her son and moved in with her daughter
and son-in-law one day she witnessed her
daughter being beaten up
he was aggressive swore and attacked her
with his fists she hid under the
blankets I ran into the room and when he
saw me he smashed the closet I said that
we would call the police and he threw us
out onto the street
this is some of the Hidden damage caused
by the war in Ukraine that goes beyond
the dead and injured the loss and
conquest of territory
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera Kiev